let's go next to JWR from Atlanta
welcome JWR
um
welcome
um thanks for having me Dave and how am
I how am I coming in as far as like the
sounds is it too rough or whatnot or
it's okay I think it's definitely doable
um I don't know if you've covered this
on your show before but what is your
take on the um
okay so in the polls it appears it
appears that work that Raphael warrenok
has uh has not a sizable but a lead over
rehearsal Walker
but then you but then there but then
there seems to be but then you look over
at the governor's race and it at best
Pierce appears to be very close between
uh between Stacey Abrams and Brian Kemp
I just wanted to hear your thoughts on
the um
your thoughts on like the possible
tickets splitting going on here and what
you think the explanation for that might
be that's a good question I don't I
don't know enough about so okay the way
these polls are typically done is people
are asked How likely are you to vote and
who do you plan to vote for how strong
is your support for that person are you
a 100 in for this person or are you
leaning that way or whatever and then
you kind of blend it and you get a final
polling number now intuitively if we're
talking about Georgia voters and you go
to Georgia voters and you pull them
about the Kemp Abrams race and you
pulled them about the Warnock Walker
race it's it's both are totally
Statewide races so everybody in the
state is allowed to vote if you have a
difference it means one of two things
some people plan to vote in one of those
races and not the other that would be
one reason right you plan to go and vote
for the Governor's race and just leave
blank the senate or you plan to vote for
different parties you might vote for
Brian Kemp the Republican for the
gubernatorial but then for Raphael
Warnock the Democrat in the senate race
which also seems kind of weird and
counter-intuitive so I I actually don't
know why you you would imagine that you
would have almost identical numbers now
there's a there's a Counterpoint to that
incumbency Stacy Abrams is the
Challenger Rafael Warnock is the
incumbent so to some degree you might
have people who are only marginally pay
attention paying attention who are just
leaning towards the person who's
currently in that office and that may be
a reason why we see different numbers
but it is sort of weird it's encounter
intuitive
right although although it could
possibly speak volumes of speak volumes
about the fact that Herschel that that
Herschel Walker is was well I won't say
a weak candidate but not maybe as strong
as some would have expected possibly
yeah I mean that's possible I I I it
would be this would be a great question
for a polling expert I feel like that we
should have on and actually ask
specifically what explains this
right I only ask the speakers like um I
I'm I'm a I'm a poll worker at Fulton
County and like I I mean like I can't I
I can't call it okay but I can't comment
in explicit detail on these things but
it is like an interest it is like an
interesting phenomenon absolutely
absolutely I'm going to look for an
expert to talk to about this I think it
is an interesting uh issue
all right thank you all right JWR thank
you so much for the call very much
appreciated